حالات وصف بعضها بالمعجزات واخرى بتحد
للطبيعه فسبل العيش تحت هذه الانقاض
لساعات وايام اسلجت قلوبا بالفعل لكنها
اثارت حيره عقول في الوقت نفسه
ليلخصها اطباء بضروره وجود طاقه هواء ولو
صغيره لاستمرار النفس والنبض معا
[موسيقى]
28 ساعه بل ثلاثمائه واكثر وقت طويل ومميت
في معظم الحالات لعالق تحت جدار ثقيل او
بين قضبان حديديه تشل حركته وتزيده صعوبه
بروده حتىمتها ثلوج متساقطه لكن وفق خبراء
كوارث الزلازل عموما لا تقتل بل البنيه
التحتيه المنهاره لافتين الى اهميه العثور
على المصابين قبل فقدان وعيهم او
الاستسلام لجراحهم ونقص الطعام او الماء
ايه جاهزين جاهزين ايجاد جيب على صغره
للاحتماء تحت الانقاض او طريقه مال الوصول
الى العناصر المطلوبه مثل الهواء والماء
من اساسيات البقاء على قيد الحياه مع
تسارع عداد الوقت بعد الكارثه حينها تتغير
التركيبه السكانيه للناجين ويصبح الحظ حلف
صغار السن اكثر
اسلحه البقاء تشمل كذلك الحاله العقليه
التي قد تؤثر بشكل كبير على المحاصرين
وفرصهم بالنجاه فجثث اقارب تحاصرهم قد
تمتص منهم الامل بالحياه تدريجيا لتبقى
اصوات المنقذين في الخارج الاكثر تاثيرا
امل حقيقي بان يصل اليهم بعد الساعه او
يوم او اسبوع قبل الاستسلام للموت وخلالها
اي شيء قابل للاكل او متاح للشرب قد يصبح
مطلوبا وفق روايات ناجين